die USA sind schon immer an Verbündeter
von Deutschland die haben uns geholfen
im Kampf gegen den Kommunismus sie
standen immer an unserer Seite und im
Rahmenwerk der NATO sind wir alliierte
vor dem Hintergrund ist es doch völlig
quatschig anzunehmen dass die USA
ausgerechnet mit Norwegen zusammen als
Mittäter Nord Stream 1 und 2 gesprengt
haben aber genau das sagt Simon Hörsch
und wem tut er damit einen Gefallen
Russland und Wladimir Putin den
russischen Diktator und das ist doch
Quatsch je mehr Verdächtige es gibt und
je mehr Zwietracht durch solche Aussagen
gesehen wird desto mehr Gefallen tun wir
Putin und deswegen dürfen wir dieser
Lüge nicht auf den Leim gehen
behauptet ja dass dieser Plan zur
Sprengung schon vor Kriegsbeginn quasi
existierte er führte eine PK von beiden
und Scholz auch ins Rennen und sagte er
sagte beiden auch man werde eben Mittel
und Wege finden es Nord Stream Probleme
zu lösen so wurde das Meer oder weniger
gesagt er wertet das als Indizes als
Drohung aber auf dem diplomatischen
Parkett werden solche Sachen halt ab und
zu mal gesagt hör äh beruft sich auf
einer einzige Quelle eine einzige Quelle
die er nicht einmal namentlich benennen
kann allein da fängt das schon an wir
haben zwei quellenprinzip im
Journalismus und wenn wir nur eine
Quelle haben dann brauchen wir Dokumente
die belegen dass das was sie sagen war
es er hat keine Dokumente er hat keine
zwei Quellen er hat irgendwie berechnet
welche Taucher da in wie viel Meter
Tiefe hätten operieren können es hat
alles hinten und vorne nicht gestimmt
also glaube ich nicht gesehen Journalist
wir stehen sie zu solchen Recherchen von
Hirsch
also ich glaube es ist erstmal
grundsätzlich gesund alle Dinge mal
kritisch zu hinterfragen und gerade wenn
man noch keine Antworten auf irgendein
bestimmte gewissen Vorgang hat zumindest
mal irgendwie mal über ein paar Theorien
nachzudenken aber was sie schon auch
richtig sagen also diese eine Quelle die
da irgendwie ihm das stecken soll er
sagt auch immer das sources oder so
ähnlich ähm da weiß ich auch nicht
ehrlich gesagt wie ich das bewerten soll
ähm vielleicht wird die werden seine
Aussagen jetzt auch aktuell ein bisschen
sehr hoch gekocht dann ist natürlich
schon so dass es ein narrativ ist der
glaube ich einigen Leuten sehr zu Gute
kommt sage ich mir in dieser dieses Land
doch sehr auf geht's Debatte die wir da
gerade führen ich würde mir sowas
anhören ähm ich würde sowas immer mal
mitnehmen ich würde immer sowas
nachdenken auch egal wie alt der Herr
ist oder was auch immer der das sagt
aber ähm ja sich ich habe auch so ein
bisschen das Gefühl dass es nicht ganz
komischer und das Motive wenn wir jetzt
darüber sprechen wie gesagt zumindest
muss man sich alles einmal anhören und
auch mal bewerten macht das Motiv dass
er ins Ziel führt irgendwie Sinn oder
haben Sie eine Theorie dazu oder haben
Sie eigene Überlegungen dazu also wir
hatten relativ Anfang an natürlich uns
Gedanken darüber gemacht wer das hätte
sein können jetzt bin ich kein
Militärexperte ja also ich kann jetzt in
dem in dem Umfang nicht beurteilen wer
da jetzt was wie machen muss klar ist
glaube ich dass dass man über eine
gewisse technologische Möglichkeiten
verfügen muss das könnten aber
Unternehmen genauso sein wie starten was
ich glaube ich viel wichtiger finde an
dieser Debatte anstatt jetzt sozusagen
ohne Beweise ist irgendwelche Theorien
durchzukauen ist eher die Frage
der Sicherheit Infrastruktur und darüber
haben wir danach klappt auch sehr viel
mehr gemacht ja dass das Infrastruktur
teilweise schlecht geschützt wird also
jetzt mal ganz salopp formuliert kann
sie jetzt dort und diese Partner einfach
hin tauchen und ihnen passiert im
Endeffekt nichts und das ist glaube ich
von dem Hintergrund dieser vielfachen
Bedrohungen die wir haben auch aus aus
ganz anderen Bereichen wichtig uns
darüber Gedanken zu machen wo wir
eigentlich Infrastruktur nachmessen
müssen gerade bei wichtiger
Infrastruktur wie geht's Ihnen mit
solchen Informationen wir haben gerade
hier am Tisch festgestellt es ist
wichtig verschiedenste Informationen zu
beleuchten jetzt stehen wir hier vor der
Frage es gibt nur eine Quelle eine
angebliche Quelle die wird nicht offen
gelegt es gibt nur Spekulationen das
werden wir hier an diesem Tisch auch
heute mit Sicherheit auflösen können
also ich gebe ihnen erstmal recht es ist
natürlich schlecht wenn man halt
Journalist nur eine Quelle hat die dann
auch noch anonym ist aber dann ist das
Simo Hirsch das muss man sagen er hat in
der Vergangenheit viele große Enthüllung
Stories gebracht auch in Serie ist es
also anzunehmen dass sie vielleicht dann
noch was kommt aber man muss nicht 7 Uhr
hörst sein ganz ehrlich um zu sehen dass
die Amerikaner keine Lust auf Nord
Stream 2 hatten und das sagen die ja
sogar selber ich möchte sie kurz daran
erinnern am 7 Dezember sagt Victoria
newtonent wenn Russland in der Ukraine
einmarschiert wird Nord Stream gestoppt
daraufhin sagt der Senator im Ausschuss
für auswärtige Beziehungen ich hoffe
dass wir ein Gesetz auf den Weg bringen
das Noten nicht nur ausgesetzt wird
sondern dauerhaft beendet wird am 7
Februar sagte dann Joe Biden in
Anwesenheit von Olaf Scholz diesen Satz
den Sie von erwähnt haben
glauben sie wir werden das tun sagt er
auf die Nachfrage der Journalist aber
wie wollen Sie denn das stoppen wenn
doch Deutschland die Chance hat oder die
Gewalt darüber hat ja
am 26 September fliegt dann Nord Stream
2 in die Luft am am 30 September sagt
der US-Außenminister das stellt jetzt
eine ungeheure Gelegenheit da ein für
alle Mal die Abhängigkeit von Putins
Energie zu beenden und ähm und am 26
Januar sagt Victoria newland die
US-Regierung ist sehr erfreut zu wissen
dass Nord Stream 2 jetzt ein Klumpen
Metall auf dem Meeresgrund ist und ähm
allein anhand dieser Sachen muss ich
sagen klingt das für mich so wie die
Amerikaner haben gesagt sie haben kein
Interesse darauf sie haben gesagt sie
werden es zerstören und es sieht so aus
als hätten sie es gemacht und wenn sie
jetzt sagen in dem in dem Zimmer Hirsch
Artikel sind auch übrigens ähm
finanzielle Motive von Norwegen erwähnt
die Norwegen vielleicht bewogen haben
damit zu machen oder wenigstens schon
ein interessanten eine interess
Synchronizität sagen wir es mal so dass
Norwegen am Tag nach der Explosion von
Nord Streams eiserner eigene
Erdgaspipeline nach Osteuropa aufgemacht
hat das also einige Daten die Herr
Fleischer hier als Indizien wertet was
sagen Sie Viktor was sagst du dazu
also ist gut dass sie ein kritischer
Nachfrage sind in allen Ehren das ist
genau richtig aber also sorry das ist
eine Verschwörungstheorie das stimmt
einfach nicht
gesagt was ist daran die
Verschwörungstheorie bezahlen kann hat
Donald Trump auch schon 2019 kurz vor
der Fertigstellung von Nord Stream 2
Sanktionen erlassen um und zwar hat er
das Gesetz zum Schutz von Europas
Energiesicherheit so hatte das genannt
die Firmen sanktioniert die an der
Fertigstellung von Nord Stream 2
mitwirken wollen sie das für sie so aus
als hätten die USA kein Interesse an der
Oder hätten als hätten ihn Interesse an
der Fertigstellung von Nord Stream 2
gehabt
Interesse daran wem spielt das alles in
die Karten ich bleibe dabei Wladimir
Putin Vladimir Putin der jede jedes Jahr
Milliarden Euro verdient hat mit seinen
Erdgas Lieferungen nach Europa hatte
also in Interesse daran seine eigene
Pipeline in die Luft zu jagen da die mir
Putin der dafür bekannt ist dass er das
Information benutzt um den Westen zu
spalten und genau das passiert ja gerade
hier am Tisch zwischen uns
entschuldigung wo ist das Information
ich habe hier Fakten genannt ich habe
gesagt Donald Trump hat Sanktionen
unterzeichnet ich habe gesagt die
obersten regierungsleute der USA haben
das gesagt wo ist da bitte
Desinformation gib ihnen recht dass die
Fakten die stimmen alle das ist richtig
aber nur weil die USA ein gewisses
wirtschaftliches Motiv haben gehen die
doch nicht hin und sprengen europäische
Infrastruktur und dann auch noch mit
Norwegen zusammen
sagt es wird kein Nord Stream 2 geben
hat haben sie sich doch nicht in die
Luft gejagt oder ich würde sagen wir
müssen ein bisschen rauszoomen und
überlegen wer hat hier wirklich die
Fäden in der Hand ich glaube das ist
aber diese diese Begriffe also
entschuldige mich in der zieht direkt
kritisiert aber ich finde glaube dieser
Begriff der Verschwörungstheorie schon
auch ganz schön überstrapaziert in der
heutigen Zeit und die glaube ich nicht
alles sie haben jetzt ganz klare Fakten
genannt was jemand gesagt hat jetzt muss
man erstmal unterscheiden auch zwischen
Interessen und der Aktion an sich ja
also man es gibt ja ganz ganz
unterschiedliche Interessen das heißt
nicht automatisch das ist die Person die
gewisses Interesse daran hat auch war so
vor allem auch vor dem Hintergrund weil
sie gerade sagt ja bekannt dafür
Desinformation zu verbreiten es ist
leider immer so ein Krieg das Wort auf
allen Seiten sehr sehr Desinformationen
bereitet wird und das gerade auch die
USA
sagen gibt es einen Adresse und einen
Angriffskrieg und ich glaube das können
wir an dieser Stelle ganz klar
festhalten Herr Schaal wir wollen sie
sich in diese Diskussion einbringen ich
finde also aus Interessen und aus
Zitaten jetzt hier eine Handlung zu
rekonstruieren und das als Beweis
heranzuführen das ja ja sie haben gesagt
es ist eine eine starke Interessenlage
und das wird das das wären Fakten das
sind keine Fakten Zitate genannt dass
diese Zitate gesagt wurden sind
vielleicht Fakten aber sie können nicht
beweisen oder herleiten dass diese diese
Handlung von den USA ausgehen nein ähm
das weiß ich auch zurück ich bin da ganz
bei bei den Kollegen Wachs zurück ins
ins Reich der Verschwörungstheorien der
US-Präsident hat gesagt wenn Russland in
der Ukraine einmarschiert wird es kein
Nord Stream 2 geben und jetzt sagen Sie
ja das hat er doch nur gesagt das ist ja
gar kein Fakt so das verstehe ich nicht
ich kann doch nicht sagen sie haben
keinen einzigen
man sagt was völlig an den Haaren
herbeigezogen
in der Pressekonferenz ist doch kein
Beweis für eine solche Haltung
also bevor ich bevor ich vermute dass
Putin ein Interesse daran hätte seine
eigene Pipeline die er selber bezahlt
hat zu großen Teilen von denen er
jahrzehntelang großes Geschäft gemacht
hätte mit Europa selber in die Luft jagt
muss ich sagen sehe ich die
Interessenlage anhand der Dinge die in
den USA geäußert wurden eher in den USA
Interesse daran dass es sofort
aufgeklärt wird damit diese ganzen
Informationen dieses Misstrauen was da
haben Sie Recht hier entsteht auf und
ich bin bei Bundesanwalt hat ja auch
gesagt es gibt keine Hinweise darauf die
das Russland dahinter steckt aber
Aufklärung funktioniert auch nur dann
wenn wir sozusagen diese Zahl diese
völlig zu Recht genannt haben weil die
Daten immer gefallen sind genauso sage
ich mal in den Grundmaterial dieser
Aufklärung wieder nach stammt irgendwie
mit einfließen lassen die vielleicht
auch viele andere Perspektive oder
Aspekte also jetzt sozusagen das eine
dann also entweder wir wollen aufklären
und dann eine Antwort haben oder wir
haben von Anfang an eine Antwort dann
brauchen wir aber nicht mehr aufklären
also dass ich ich will nur ich sage
nicht dass ich sage nur ich sage nur
dass wir uns glaube ich in unseren
aufklärungs Bemühungen die Aufklärung
funktioniert immer immer besser ihr
offener wird zumindest an so eine
Aufklärungsprozess reingehen die die
Sprengung dieser Pipeline fällt doch in
einen Zeitraum in dem klar war dass
Russland überhaupt kein verlässlicher
Energielieferant mehr für und sein kann
und überhaupt kein verlässlicher Partner
mehr sein kann also das heißt ähm rein
faktisch war doch schon diese Pipeline
längst geschlossen ja aber ist das jetzt
der Grund warum putiner sagt gut dann
eben nicht jetzt ja er spielt mit
unseren Ängsten er hat diese Pipeline
springen lassen um sie dann sozusagen
deaktiv Faktor zu versperren und dann
zu machen
das mit unserem Gaspreis hier die Ängste
in Europa geschildert haben uns
auseinander zu spalten das hat der Wachs
richtig gesagt den Westen zu zu
ängstigen überhol-gaspreise damit
verloren also wenn Sie wenn Sie wo sind
jetzt ihre Fakten sozusagen wie sie das
untermauern das ist der Faktor war also
der hat gar nicht Aufklärung jetzt sagen
Sie es wahr sein alles auf oder haben
wir jetzt die Fakten schon es muss auch
es muss aufgeklärt werden aber man kann
entscheiden muss weiter aufgeklärt
werden Fall wird ja auch noch untersucht
aber die Zitate die Zitate du
US-Präsidenten hinzulegen und sagen das
wäre jetzt jeder Beweis das kann ich
richtig sagen es muss aufgeklärt werden
das sagen alle hier im Tisch ich glaube
zumindest da herrscht